[Musik]
ja du kannst jetzt den anfang machen
meine hase im pfeffer
ich habe meiner deswegen habe ich auch
diese kapuze wir haben halt noch ein
bisschen schlaf nachgeholt deswegen
sehen die haben so schlimm aus aber
leichter was geht ab herzlich willkommen
bei alex neuen video wollte das geht aus
willkommen zu diesem neuen video ich bin
nur ganz kurz hier weil ich dachte dass
auch eigentlich noch gar nichts denn
jetzt habe ich allerdings schon einen
polier gesehen aber ist nicht schlimm
und zwar geht es heute nach langer zeit
mal wieder um klamotten ich dachte wir
immer bei junk ja das ist ein onlineshop
klamotten aussuchen und dieses mal haben
wir das so gemacht da ist nichtig das
ausgesucht habe sondern marie mir für
diesen bestimmten betrag den ich dann
immer frei zu verfügen habe klamotten
aussuchen durfte und das hat sie gemacht
die sind doch schon angekommen
sie möchte euch jetzt erst einmal die
ganzen klamotten zeigen und dazu
vielleicht was sagen müsste und dann und
dann werde ich natürlich mal anprobieren
allerdings ist hier schon dunkel draußen
das müssen wir auf morgen verschieben
aber ist ja gar kein problem und ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt was da ist warum
gekommen ist und ob du meinen geschmack
getroffen ist okay meinte ich habe mal
ein paar sachen ausgesucht wo ich dachte
die könnten allerdings gefallen muss
allerdings sagen das werden sehr
unterschiedlich nicht mehr kam deswegen
weiß ich überhaupt nicht ob das tal ex
geschmack entspricht oder nicht
aber mal schauen erstmal habe ich hier
diese schuhe die fand ich ganz cool bei
ich persönlich mag eine schlichte schuhe
und ich glaube die kann man halt gut auf
alles kombinieren da habe ich dieses t
shirt
dann habe ich dieses t shirt mit dem
hintergedanken dass das auch anziehen
kann
es ist nämlich unisex leute nicht cool
alex marx gerne körper klamotten dann
diese riba kusel dazu habe ich mich noch
einmal finde ich ganz schillig fallen
stark gefühlt man jogginghosen dieses
dann das habe ich auch wieder bestellt
weil sex ist dass man nicht ganz cool
das war nicht ganz cool war alex gerne
farbe trägt und auch gerne auffällige
farben bei dem will ich mir absolut und
sicher sieht an dem model echt cool aus
ist nicht so ganz mein aber da alex sehr
gerne orange trägt dachte ich mir kann
man ja mal ausprobieren dann einmal den
pulli weil alex ja immer gerne
astronauten futter ist für ist dann habe
ich dem gestellt dem finde ich richtig
schön aber ich weiß nicht ob der alex
stehen
den darf ich nicht um alle
allerschönsten er ist vom tommy hilfiger
und der ist in neongelb und wie ihr seht
traurig sehr sehr gerne da diese ja ich
finde hier sehen ein bisschen aus wie
timbaland von vieler finde ich auch
richtig süß da würde ich ganz cool kann
man glaube ich ganz gut kombinieren also
sie alle gleich bisschen helfen wie
viele verschlossen wir uns geholt zwei
bin jetzt mein absolutes favorite peace
ist diese hier vor ort facebook ich bin
ich richtig cool was anderes ist die
sind halt sehr sportlich aus aber auch
irgendwie eleganter nicht bereit ist ich
glaube dass es auch das letzte teil er
ist dieser puli khumri bock bei dem bin
ich mir noch unsicher weil ich mag
eigentlich die lieder nicht und ich mag
eigentlich diese stickies nicht aber in
kombination miteinander könnte ist
wieder cool aus ihrem alex steht auf
sowas deswegen ja leute also das war es
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was er
denn da haben so leute wir haben jetzt
den nächsten tag und es ist ziemlich
helden deswegen gern ich habe hier keine
software ag ist ein bisschen sonne ich
gerade alles aber ist ja gar kein
problem
super maries auf jeden fall hinter der
kamera
die suche hat schon die autos zusammen
und schmeißt mir die gleich rüber wir
machen das heute mal wie in alten
youtube zeiten ich habe dafür auch gerne
mal fashion holz gedreht das heißt du
willst mir die praktisch rüber und ich
habe die dann automatisch an ok
verstehst du ich meine nein das hat
nichts mit schnitt zu tun
okay ich bin mal gespannt ich sehe die
sache jetzt schon aber
zu einer sache muss ich sagen die schule
hatte ich leider schon einmal an also
weil ich brauche letzten zwei schuhe für
einen wirklich wichtigen anlass und ich
hatte keine schuhe mehr die wirklich
weiß waren deswegen sind die schuhe die
eigentlich weiß waren jetzt auch nicht
mehr ganz weiß ja erstmal muss ich wohl
jetzt nur lose anziehen
also ich ziehe jetzt gerade eine hose an
kunden mehrheit weil ich habe dieses
jahr gar keine hosen bestellt außer
ausserrhoder was dazu bestellt eine hose
haben wir nur dabei deswegen muss sich
jetzt hoffmann wurde von jan o
so leute fangen wir mal an mit einem t
shirt
ja aber das muss ja trotzdem zeigen dass
sie just wir auch bestellt oder nicht
mit einem t shirt von vieler das ist
hier irgendwie so drauf gestickt fühlt
sich ganz meistern eigentlich ich war
jetzt wohl raus wieder 18 grad sind kann
man ja auch mein t shirt gebrauchen und
das kann noch ein pulli dazu ja einfach
zum drüberziehen wo er den finde ich
auch ganz neues von nasa den wollte ich
mir sogar schon mal einmal kaufen aber
der sitzt nicht so gut also der ist echt
englisch stehen mehr so oft bisschen
wasser ist ja wird wird er das ist
überhaupt nicht mal jetzt einfach dieses
hochgekrempelt dass wir nicht warum
sollen wir eine hohe hochkrempeln ist
kalt hier und ok jetzt kommt noch die
schuhe dazu also das sind die schuhe die
ich jetzt schon kenne
sinn von adidas zu den namen weiß ich
gar nicht genau habe ich euch auf jeden
fall in der video beschreibung verlinkt
übrigens wenn ihr da was bestellen
sollte bekommt ihr mit dem code der hier
eingebunden ist auch eine bestellung von
über 50 euro 15 prozent rabatt ist ja
gar nicht schlecht ich glaube der
schultoilette also solche schuhe finde
ich extrem nice für den sommer die ziehe
ich jetzt mal nach zu anfällt man
irgendwas eine jacke leute hier
verzichte ich jetzt mal auf den effekt
wir haben ja eine winterjacke
hast du mal die temperaturen draußen
gesehen ein spaß das wird bestimmt
wieder kälter ich fahre noch im
skiurlaub also sportlich unterwegs würde
ich mal sagen hier oder wie das outfit
aussieht das zeige ich euch genau jetzt
viel spaß
[Musik]
so leute aus schritt nummer eins kann
ich wieder ausziehen
also ich muss sagen die jacke für mich
wirklich extrem gut also die jetzt so
richtig gut hallo hier kannst du
wirklich sehr sehr gut ausgesucht so
eine wollte schon immer haben wir
normalerweise als kind habe ich immer
nur diese wie sagt man also diese mäntel
jacken und natürlich sagen über zum
nächsten outfit leute als nächstes haben
wir oder es bisschen oversized finde ich
eigentlich ganz gut
die von adidas abgesehen steht hinten
auch was steht da drauf hin also ich
muss sagen dieses outfit gefällt mir
endlich besser als das davor so viel für
die für die jetzigen temperaturen schaut
mal rein kurs
[Musik]
so stellt zum nächsten auftritt jetzt
habe ich gehört muss ich auch plötzlich
mal wieder meine hose ausziehen wollte
diese weise habe ich schon länger
die ist nicht dazu gestellt aber die
sehe ich jetzt einfach mal mit dem holy
jetzt was jetzt kommen was leuchtendes
was das denn ist irgendwie was für links
für die müllabfuhr oder so was habe ich
noch nie gesehen was mit seinem mit
einem tuch hier direkt vor für den
winter leute und dazu hier diese schuhe
von vieler hast du glaub ich schon mal
gezeigt eben nicht ganz nice ich hatte
so ähnlich schon mal drei mal muss sagen
ich glaube ich war hier mit auf weil das
ja besonders wichtig als youtuber du
musst ja auffallen oder leute was man
hat so auf jeden fall auch sagen muss
das ist ein bisschen sie natürlich auch
mit der jogginghose aber das ist einfach
mein style ich lauf fünf tage in der
woche eigentlich ein akteur geholt hast
du ja ich bin ja ums geld ok jetzt würde
ich gerne mal diesen leuchten in politik
hin wollte er gefällt mir glaube ich
ganz gut leute hier haben wir einen rudi
von tommy jeans tommy hilfiger ist es
nicht und hier muss ich sagen
der sitzt direkt richtig gut feiern ich
bis jetzt am meisten also den hast du
recht gut ausgesucht wieder aus sie
zeigen gleich mal eben bis gleich
[Musik]
so leute was soll das denn hier kommen
wir zum letzten outfit da freue ich mich
auch drauf kann das sein dass die hose
über den pulli lag nämlich leichte grüne
stimmte jetzt hier dran ist von reebok
eine dunkle hose geht macht die finde
ich auch gut also ist auf jeden fall ein
gutes t shirt gefällt mir schon hast gut
ausgesucht ok und jetzt kommt man auch
zum letzten politik der passt zu hause
war
lieber wäre mir auch wenn baku die sich
mal kurz an gemeinen special effekt noch
okay leute das war's mit dem video
alle klamotten stücke sind und in der
video beschreibung von links ist auf
jeden fall ab wenn du da von irgendwas
cool findet wir sehen uns morgen wieder
da gibt es wieder eine normales video
und ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
lassen da schreibt man die kommentare
welche style euch am besten gefallen hat